- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here.
Welcome to our Homeroom ive
stream, ever exciting show.
We're gonna have Kristen DiCerbo,
Khan Academy's Chief
Learning Officer answering
any questions you have about motivation
and having more independence as a learner.
But before we get started,
I will make my standard announcements.
First, a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself
if you're in a position to do so.
So please think about going
to Khanacademy.org/donate
and making a donation.
Also wanna give a special shout
out to several organizations
that have supported Khan
Academy through the years
but especially as we went into COVID,
our costs went up as we're trying
to accelerate a whole series of programs,
our server costs have gone up.
So special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, Novartis,
and to the many other organizations
that have supported Khan
Academy through the years.
It's made a huge difference,
although we still need more help.
So now please think
about making a donation.
I'd also like to announce,
and I've done this on
previous live streams
that we have a Homeroom
with Sal the podcast,
as you can see in that
graphic right over there
which are kind of some of
the more notable moments
in this Homeroom live stream.
So encourage you to go wherever you
find your podcast subscribe to it.
Hopefully you get a kick out of it.
So with that, I'm excited to
introduce kristen DiCerbo,
who we've had on before.
Kristen, good to see you.
- Hey Sal, good to be here to be here.
- So, for those of y'all who don't know,
Kristen is Khan Academy's
Chief Learning Officer
which means that she
keeps us well informed
and deep on everything
regarding learning Science
and academics and the best
way that folks can learn
and help others learn.
So Kristen, what I want to understand
is what tips do you have?
The question I get a lot is
how do we keep people motivated right now,
how do we keep people engaged,
how do we kids are a
lot more of independence
as expected of them.
So what tips do you have
for students and parents
and teachers trying to navigate this?
- Yes, that is the question all of us
here at Khan Academy are getting a lot of,
so it's clearly something
that people are struggling
with quite a bit.
As you said, I like to
look to the research
and see what it says.
And when you look across things,
we can actually think pretty simply about
what keeps people motivated, two things.
First, we're motivated to do things
when we think we're gonna
feel successful at them
which kind of makes sense.
Like who wants to do something
if you think you're gonna fail at it.
Doesn't seem very fun.
And then second, if we value the activity.
If it's something that's important to us.
So really we can boil there on a lot of
the tips and ideas and things
to things that are either going
to help us feel successful
or increase our perception of
the value of the activity we're doing
and sometimes both of those things.
So that's kind of the
simple way of the land.
And so to your question
about a couple of tips.
One really powerful thing
we can do, is to set goals.
Because goal setting
and then monitoring
ourselves, hits on both
of those two things
about success and value.
And so if I set a goal
or if you're a parent
or a teacher and you work with
the kid to set the goal,
so not just impose it on them,
but let them help you think about
what should your goal be?
That gives you some buy-in
it increases the value
because you're thinking, yeah I'm gonna,
this is something I care about.
I'm gonna set the goal to be something
that's important to me.
And then, as you watch
yourself make progress
toward that goal and actually reach it,
it turns out you're experiencing success
and there's nothing that convinces you
you might be successful in the future.
Like actually having some success.
So these can be little goals,
it can be I'm gonna write five sentences
and then, hey, I wrote six, that's great.
It can be I'm gonna do
this many math problems.
Start out small don't be like,
I'm gonna learn all of algebra
in this next two months.
That's too long, it's too much
you're gonna not be able to sustain that.
So keep it small, but
be able to think about,
what some of those achievable things
that you can do are.
- I like that.
So the two big takeaways,
you should have a reasonable chance of,
or belief that you can be successful
or feeling a successful
and it should be fun.
But let me ask a question
sometimes like I'm
a hobbyist guitarist for example.
And it's very tempting for me to in
the spirit of wanting to feel successful,
kind of play the songs that I already know
because I know I'll succeed at them
and it's fun 'cause I can
kind of get into the more.
Is that what you're saying?
Like, should I not challenge myself?
Should I not try the songs
that I'm still fumbling through
these bizarre chords and whatever else?
- That's definitely not what we wanna say.
In fact, we wanna think about
how we can keep moving forward.
And one of the ways
that we can frame that,
is actually to think about
this idea of growth mindset
which has gotten a lot of play lately
and sometimes it feels
like, Oh, growth mindset
is just saying, hey, work hard
and you can do it.
But when it comes to learning,
what we know is that when
you're learning new things,
you're actually changing
how your brain works.
And we actually have a course,
how to the courses section down there
in the life skills.
And it actually walks students through
some of these ideas about how
our brain actually changes
the neurons little cells in our brains
when we're learning new things,
make new connections.
And we can we explain that in some videos
and students can walk
through it a little bit.
But this idea that your brain
is actually like a muscle.
It's like when you're working out.
And if you keep lifting heavier weights,
your muscles get bigger in the same way
that if you keep learning new things,
your brain actually gets denser
and it turns out dense
brains are a good thing.
And you can learn new
things and build them.
So if you keep playing
your same songs over
and over again, you're not building any of
these new muscle and this new
connections in your brain.
But if you're trying new things,
you're going to keep improving.
And next time you'll be able to play
even more complicated songs
and maybe some other songs
that you're interested in learning.
- So if I were to kind of figure out
the sweet spot there you
definitely shouldn't work
on the stuff that is,
you're definitely going to succeed on
because that's not going to stretch you
and grow those neural connections.
And maybe don't work on the thing that is,
for me the Eddie van Halen level
because I might not become...
- I was gonna say what's
this, super hard guitar.
(laughing)
- I avoid that, but try the stuff
that's stretching me a little bit.
And another thing I took away from you
is when someone calls me dance
which has happened.
I take that as a compliment from now on.
- You should absolutely take
that as a compliment.
- I'm sure they're referring
to my neural density when
they say that I'm dance.
- Exactly.
- So we have questions,
I encourage everyone to ask questions.
Any questions really about learning,
about learning science
but education Khan Academy
for Kristen and myself if relevant.
We have a few questions
that are all coming in
from Facebook, Cindy Victor Kumpen asks,
my boy went to school for four years
and it took away all of his motivation.
It was boring every day.
How can I help him getting
enthusiastic again,
getting back on track?
Your advice, Kristen?
- Well, first I'm sorry to hear that.
That he's not still excited about learning
and where those things are.
So there's a couple
things that I would say.
So one is, you know him
better than anyone else
and you can help him make
the connections between
what he's learning and the
things he's interested in.
So when we talked about that value,
one way that we value
things we're doing is
because they seem relevant to us.
So if you know the things
that he's learning,
help him make those connections
between why am I learning this
and what it can do to relate to
other things I'm interested in,
questions he's asked about the world
and how it works, things he
wants to be when he grows up.
Any of those kinds of things,
the way a way to help him see some of
the meaning in the things
that he's being asked to do.
So that's one way that
you can start bringing
some of that piece back.
And the other thing is
I would say at home,
really encourage those questions
and think about how
he's thinking about how
the world works and wondering about this
or the other thing and
when I peddle my bike,
why does that make the wheel move
and start even modeling, asking
those kinds of questions.
And those are the things
that then help you relate back to
the things that the students are learning.
- And I'll just add to that.
I think there's two reasons
why I've seen either myself
or other folks disengage
or feel something's boring.
Oftentimes you feel that it's boring
because you're ready to move ahead
but you you're getting impatient
or sometimes you feel it's boring
that it's a little overwhelming,
it's all going over
your head, so to speak.
And so one option,
and I know a good website for this
or a good series of apps,
especially in math and science,
but we have some resources
and other things.
But if your son I believe it was
goes on to Khan Academy is able
to put even 20, 30 minutes a day.
Start at their level it sounds like
your son's been going to
school for about four years,
so maybe they're in fourth or fifth grade.
Start them even at the kindergarten level
or start them on the get
ready for fourth grade
or get ready for fifth grade
course on Khan Academy.
That will allow them to
fill in all their gaps,
probably build a little bit of confidence.
It will be a little bit of
playing those guitar songs
that he already knows,
but he might realize that a few
of his chords need a
little bit more practice
than he appreciates.
And then when he gets to the grade level
of course, he can learn about
that in his own time and pace.
And then he'll probably
not only get caught up
with his class if he
wasn't already caught up,
but probably get ahead of his class.
And you know what I found
and I'm even speaking
from personal experience.
Once you see academic success in one area,
you naturally start to get
more curious, more engaged,
your perception of yourself starts to say,
I'm a learner, I'm capable of learning
and I don't have to wait for other people
to tell me what to learn.
I can do this on my own.
And then that can bleed
over into other things
that can bleed on to being
curious about science
or humanities or politics
or whatever else.
And a lot of what Kristen
just mentioned of,
the real world, how does
it all fit together?
I think you have a better shot of that.
So let's see other questions here.
So this from Greenwich
Connecticut, Kimberly's asking,
how do I know if my child is learning
if he isn't tested?
Kimberly has children
in grades three, six,
and eight, eighth grade.
So how do you know if they're learning
if they are not tested?
Good question, Kristen your view.
- That is a good question.
So first, talk to your child's
teachers about what are
the skills that they're
supposed to be learning.
So not what score they get on a test,
but what are the things
that they should know how to do?
What are the ideas
that they should start
to be understanding?
And then, there's a couple
of things you can do.
So first is in that
conversation with the teacher,
get their thoughts about, okay,
where do you think my child is
and getting to do those things.
But you can also just
start observing the things
and when you're at home and think about,
asking them questions,
having those conversations with them
that gives you some evidence about, hey,
how well did I think they
understand where this is
and what this looks like?
The other thing that I would say
is I've done a lot of kind of thinking
and writing about the idea
of assessment without tests.
And the idea is that particularly now
that we're in this digital world,
we can get quite a bit of information
as students are doing learning activities.
Again, another shameless plug for
the Khan Academy website
that helps students
be able to see whether
what kind of level they're at
or have they mastered the skill or not.
Without actually taking a test,
they're getting kind of through
their practice activities.
They are leveling up from
kind of being familiar to
the task, to proficient with the task.
And so by gathering that
data from digital activities,
we actually can eliminate some of the need
for the testing that's
kind of a big pressure
on teachers time and on students time,
it leads to anxiety and all
of those kinds of things.
And instead of we can get information
from them as they're learning,
to be able to understand.
- Yeah, I'll just underline
that last point of
practice on Khan Academy
isn't just practice.
It's inherently a little micro assessment
every time a student engages.
And so that is also a good way to read.
And we've seen correlations,
very strong correlations
between work on Khan Academy
and other types of benchmark assessments.
So that's, yeah completely agree.
So from Facebook, there's a
question Jamie Dawson Osborne
is asking what about when
students don't understand
and the teacher's hands are tied
with how they can teach the lesson.
So how does either the student,
the parent or the teacher
deal with that Kristen?
- I'm not sure what hands are tied imply.
(laughing)
- My interpretation is the
teacher has to cover with
the negative exponents
and say a seventh grade math class.
But the students still doesn't
understand basic exponents,
but the teacher feels I have to cover
this negative exponents standard
because that's what my
pacing guide I got from
the district tells me to do.
How much of the various
parties do in that scenario,
and you can imagine that's
very disengaging for students.
- Absolutely.
And I think what we
often see is this tension
that you've talked about a lot
between having to keep
marching forward according
to what is in the scope and sequence,
we call it, that list of
what needs to be taught
when in the school year
versus making sure students
have time to master what they're doing.
And we really need the balance
of both of those things,
because I'm looking at it is important
that students have exposure to all of
that grade level work.
And on the other hand,
it's also important that
they have the opportunity
to fill in gaps of things that maybe
they didn't quite master before
or they have the time to do this.
And so one of the things that we encourage
is this idea of thinking
about potentially spending
four days of the classroom per week on
that grade level material.
And then one day on what we
call Personalized Practice,
the idea that you can
start working with students
at the level where they are
thinking about filling in
some of those gaps,
understanding where they are,
what maybe didn't quite get to mastery on
and giving them additional practice
and instruction in those areas so that
they can would then when they do again,
get back to that grade level material,
they're ready for it and able to do it.
So I think that's one thing.
The other thing that came to mind with
the hands are tied piece is that sometimes
the teachers explaining it
and explaining it in the way
that they think about it,
but just hearing someone
else explaining it
can give you, Oh, aha, now I get it.
And so that's another way
that some of our videos.
I think it could be helpful is
that they provide a little bit
different way to explain it
or to think about it
that someone hasn't maybe heard before.
- Very, very helpful.
Yeah, I completely agree.
I think in that case,
whatever we can do to help
that student fill in their gaps
so that they can engage,
it's going to be optimal.
So a couple of related
questions Rifat Tanvir
from Facebook is asking,
do you think motivation is an illusion
they've been watching motivational videos
but they feel like it hasn't
been helpful for them.
A similar question from
YouTube, Miss Victoria,
the eyes are all numbers there,
but how can you become
more self-motivated?
So yeah, you hear this
thing like motivation.
Yes, so and so is motivated.
So, and so is not motivated.
What is that?
Is that like some, do we
have like a motivation gene?
Is it contextual?
Can you improve it?
- So absolutely it is not something
that's preprogrammed in you
and you either are or are not.
It's very much contextual
you can be motivated
to do one thing and not
motivated to do something else
and that's very common.
I hear lots of parents say, gosh
my kid seems really
motivated to play Minecraft,
but not motivated at all to read books.
So it's definitely something
that you can think about changing to
the point of is it
the thing that's not gonna change it,
is like motivational slogans.
So just, hey keep working,
hey you're doing great.
Like, people don't really believe that
if it's not their experience.
And so there's definitely,
we wanna think about that,
this idea of authentic success
and giving these messages
about why we think
that they can do this
and why we think they'll be successful
which goes back to some of the things
we were talking about earlier about,
if you understand how this is
actually changing your brain
and how working hard can actually lead
to those kinds of
changes and improvements.
That then can help think about, okay,
now I understand why I might be motivated
as opposed to just keep working hard.
So doing that, getting some of
that kind of authentic
success going in is important.
And then as we think about how to,
one of the things that
research talks about a lot
is a difference between what
they call external motivation
and intrinsic motivation.
And so external motivation
is being motivated by things
from the outside.
So like getting rewards
for what you're doing
and intrinsic is being motivated
from internal things
because it makes you happy,
it brings you joy, you
find it interesting.
And so one of the questions
is how to move kids
from not wanting to do something
to maybe being internally
motivated to do it.
And so I get also a lot of questions about
is giving my kids rewards
just bribing them,
that seems wrong.
But it's okay to use
rewards sometimes to bridge
the gap between, I don't wanna do this
and to get a little taste of it.
That getting a little success
that will lead them to success.
So it's not bad to think
about small rewards
and talking about maybe
it's playing a board game,
maybe it's picking what's for dinner.
Those kinds of things is
rewards that something
that's meaningful for
your student, your kid
that gives them a little
reason to try something
and then give them experience of it
that they can then build on.
So that's one of the ways we can think
about kind of moving towards being
more intrinsically motivated.
- I like that and it resonates with me
and it makes me feel
less guilty last night
for bribing my kids with
being able to watch Shira
so that they can take a bath.
But I would like to believe
that extrinsic motivation over time,
they will recognize the
intrinsic benefits of being clean
and not stinky.
- You've also got society helping you
with that a little bit once
they start getting more of that.
(laughing)
- That might be extrinsic motivation too.
When you're stinky,
people might give you
some external feedback
that makes you realize
that you need to take a bath.
More questions here.
So how do you,
this is from Facebook
Andrea Houk Lara says,
how do you motivate preschoolers
in a virtual classroom?
- There's one of the things to think about
with kids who are really bad age
is not even motivation,
but just attention spans
and making sure first that you
have realistic expectations
of what a preschooler
can do in a zoom class.
We're talking fairly shorts timeframes,
a few minutes on any particular activity.
If you look to things like Sesame Streets,
in terms of how they're
switching to a new thing
that they're doing.
We can't expect, we
shouldn't expect preschoolers
to be able to sit for
a 30 minute zoom class
doing all of the same kind of activity.
So one, you're gonna wanna
talk to your child's teacher,
make sure that they're doing,
making those switches to
doing different things,
thinking about how you're
structured in that time
that they're expected to be in.
So that's the first thing I would say.
And so then the second
piece is just thinking about
what is it that is in those activities
that is related to things
that they're excited about,
things that they're interested in,
make those connections.
Hey, did you ever wonder why are our dog
and our cats one goes
out for a walk every day
and the cat doesn't, I don't know.
Just like silly questions
that you might be able to think about
and think about how, what they're doing in
the classroom can bring
those kinds of ideas in.
But with younger kids again,
manage your expectations
about what they're gonna be able
to do in this environment.
- Yeah, now it makes a lot of sense.
And I would just add to that
I have my youngest is almost six,
five and a half years old
and what I've seen his
teachers do really well
is just to quirky funny
things all the time,
intersperse whatever they're trying to do
with just some goofiness,
some moving around
and to your point Kristen,
like not do long stretches
and four or five or six year old,
a long stretch could even
be 15 minutes or 20 minutes.
But try to break it up and try to make
it as interactive as possible.
I also do wanna make sure
folks tune in for tomorrow
as there gonna be a 100th show
and the person who can help answer
some of these questions about
motivating kindergartners
and preschoolers, Tabatha Rosproy.
She's a 2020 National Teacher of the Year.
So hopefully she can give us some tips
as well on motivating that crowd
which I'm sure I can
benefit from here at home.
So, from YouTube I have a question...
- I would also say just to echo that,
that teachers have great
experience doing this
and the lots of good tips.
So, just echo encouraging
people to tune in for that.
- Yeah, my other last
tip and I would even call
this a pro tip 'cause I'm not a pro
by any stretch of
imagination is stick with
the young kids even they are very capable
of eventually forming
some of these habits.
And once they see some wins,
they too can get a little
bit more motivated.
Well, I've seen that with
my own with my own son
who's five since distance
learning started.
So from YouTube Kaushik Jha says
I started feeling depressed
and thinking about goals, COVID
literally makes me go through anxiety.
So what advice do you have for that Kris?
I don't think Kaushik is alone.
I think there's a lot of folks
that you have COVID, you have the economy,
you have other stuff going on in the world
that is causing a lot of stress
and then on top of that,
people are trying to figure out
their own life and I don't know if Kaushik
is a student or is working or whatever
but what are your goals?
I'm I achieving what I need to?
Is it easier or harder now
I'm less connected with friends.
How do you recommend people navigate this
and maybe try to try to get out of that
and try to maybe hopefully
make some forward progress
on some of their goals.
- Absolutely, so I'm gonna take this from
first starting just from
the learning perspective
which and just say, keep it simple.
We don't have to do everything
while we're in this COVID situation.
We'll be out of it at some point.
We'll get a vaccine,
we'll be able to go out in the world.
If we can just make sure we're keeping up
the foundations right now,
that's the important thing.
So for younger kids, just make sure
they're doing some math,
they're doing some reading,
they're getting some
keeping up their curiosity
about the world.
Those are really the important
things that you're doing.
For students that are a
little bit older again,
think about what are the
most important things
for them to be learning this year.
What are the biggest pieces
that we wanna make sure they get?
And let yourself go with all of the things
that come up in terms of
learning on top of that.
It's okay if you don't get them now.
We're all really resilient
and we'll be able to pick up again when
this is all off and we
can get back together
and do in person, learning and focus again
on all of these things.
So that's my first thing is,
it's okay if you're not doing everything
that you were doing in the before times.
So it's okay when you set goals,
we talked about progress monitoring there,
make sure you're on track,
but another skill is actually realizing
when this isn't gonna work.
I can't do this right now.
In modifying what your goals are
and thinking about whether maybe
it's you're gonna extend
the time it takes to meet that goal.
Maybe you're gonna change what
the goal is a little bit.
That's okay, our goals don't have,
we're not like carved in stone.
We can change them.
And it's actually quite a skill
to be able to recognize
when you're off track
and be able to find ways
to either get on track
or to modify where what your past is
and where you think you're gonna go.
We say one more thing,
I also have a background
as a School Psychologist.
And if you feel like the anxiety
that you're experiencing is
interfering with your work
in your life and that worry
the thoughts you're having
are actually interfering
with kind of the daily
things you need to do,
don't be afraid to seek
help for that either.
If you've got kids, you can
talk to their pediatrician,
you can talk to your general
practitioner for some advice
and help as well but make sure
that you're staying healthy.
- Yeah, I'll just echo that
last point Kristen made.
Sometimes you're like a
frog in boiling water.
You don't realize that
things are getting bad
until they maybe get too bad.
And so very as soon as you get a sense,
it never hurts to go talk to folks,
get help, et cetera, et cetera.
The other thing I would throw out is,
sometimes if your goals are too ambitious,
that can become debilitating
because they feel daunting
or they feel very hard to start on.
And I think one thing that
I've heard from Kristen,
not just over the last several minutes
but in the past is just of your goals
need to be things that
you can get some wins on
so that you can kind of
notch them in your belt
and move on from that.
The other thing I'd recommend is,
and I've talked about this before
is try out meditation.
Meditation it isn't some weird thing.
All it is, is sitting quietly
and becoming observant of your thoughts
and then letting your
mind still a little bit.
And you'll realize that
a lot of those anxieties,
a lot of those maybe
even negative feelings,
they come from a part of your brain,
but that isn't your entire self.
I wouldn't call that a substitute
for getting help if you need it.
But look into it even if you're able
to do two, three minutes a day,
I've talked about before.
I used to get anxious on planes.
I still go do a little bit.
But by meditating, it
really helped me actually
not only not get anxious on planes,
but in a lot of other circumstances
where I might have otherwise
gotten a little bit worked up.
So we have time maybe
for one more question
from Facebook Rohonie Arjune is at saying,
my child although very chatty
and extroverted at home with
and with the family,
he's extremely shy with
speaking up on video
with his teacher in class.
How can I motivate his participation?
I've actually heard this
a lot, Kristen ideas.
- Yeah, so there's a
couple of things to do.
So one, is make sure that you know
what is the kind of
importance of speaking out.
So sometimes it's not that important
if they're not sharing all the time
and they're a little bit more quiet
and that can be okay.
But one of the things that
speaking out actually does
is it helps us work through
the ideas that we're learning.
If you explain them in your own words,
back to the teacher or
you're answering a question
for the teacher, what that's
doing is you're putting
into your own words the
things you're learning
and you give the teacher the opportunity
to maybe correct what's going on there.
So if you understand, if
that's one of the purposes,
you wanna figure out how
to make sure your child's
getting that experience.
So it might be actually talking
to you a little bit about what are
the things that they are learning,
what are the things, how
would they have answered
that question that maybe
they didn't speak up
to answer so that you can work with them
to do that too
Second, make sure they
know like the protocols,
what are the norms in their classroom
for speaking up?
I know I get on calls
where there's 10 people,
just 10 people online,
and it's really hard to like get in,
like to get heard and then it's your turn.
And so find out how do they,
is there a virtual hand
raising function in
the platform you use?
Is there a way that they can,
how do they indicate when they
do have something to say
that they want to say something
and make sure they know how to that,
that's the next piece.
And then finally think about the,
in the same ways that we
talked about motivating
to do anything.
How can we think about setting some goals
around how many times,
hey, let's see if you
can speak up two times
in this next hour long class
and contribute to the discussion
and say where those are.
So those kinds of think
about those same principles.
If they're not doing it,
do you wanna bring in
some external rewards
for them when they do do that?
And finally just make
sure you've always got
that connection to your child's teacher
so that your child's teacher's aware
that maybe they're having
some of these worries
and some of these concerns
about how to speak up as well.
So those are some individual
thoughts there about
how to get kind of kids
going in these zoom calls.
We've probably all
experienced it ourselves.
- No, absolutely I think I've been on
some of those calls
with Kristen where have
trouble getting in.
I hope it wasn't my fault.
Well, Kristen thank you so much.
I hope we do this again.
As you can see, a lot of folks have
a lot of questions about
engagement and motivation.
So I don't think this is
the end of our conversation,
but thanks so much for it...
- let me just say,
actually if you have more questions,
we're doing a Webinar next week
and you can sign up.
It's the place you see here.
So one more plug before
we go, September 30th,
four Pacific, seven Eastern.
- Awesome.
Thanks Kristen.
Yeah, definitely join that Webinar
a lot more good information
like you just got.
Also wanna remind everyone
for tomorrow's Live stream
on National 2020 Teacher of the Years
as I mentioned Tabitha Rosproy
and we're gonna be able to talk about,
well she's national teacher of the year,
but especially working with younger kids.
So I think we'll be able to continue some
of these questions we've
been talking about,
about motivation,
especially with younger kids
and distance learning.
So look forward to
seeing you all tomorrow.
Have a good day.